it's been almost a year and a half since
Hillary Clinton's political career was
buried by the landslide electoral
victory of Donald J Trump but just like
that baby duck I fed once she won't go
away
look at this I am really committed to
speaking out and doing what I can to
have a voice in the debate I'm gonna you
know keep writing and keep talking and
keep supporting people or on the front
lines of the resistance I won the places
that are optimistic diverse dynamic
moving forward and his whole campaign
make America great again was looking
backwards uh yeah
Trump was looking backwards so we can
see your face when you came in second
sick burn
thankfully there are wise voices out
there on Fox News and Infowars
who have the courage to tell this
retired grandmother that she needs to
shut the heck up and disappear Hillary
Clinton needs to go away
you know why won't Hillary go away there
are women actual women who are Democrats
who are telling her go away I don't even
know what to say about her anymore
I really don't yeah and the last time
Jesse Watters didn't have something to
say was when that judge asked him to
repeat what he yelled in Chinatown
I'm sick of talking about you Hilary I
only have so many different ways to say
shrimp pitchy but that's my last one so
go away scram
vamanos but in English by Hillary we
don't need you we'll be right back Chuck
get back in here
come on okay okay good are the Liberals
gun has anyone ever tried a cauliflower
pizza crust okay yeah they're gone good
because this is just between us opposers
we need Hillary Clinton she's basically
the whole GOP strategy for winning the
midterms without her to crap on our
candidates have nothing to stand for
Republicans have already given up on
legislating this year and it's only
April we need a villain to rally against
if there was no Joker in Gotham Batman
would just be some rich weirdo in a cape
masking it up with a boy Acrobat he's
not even related to me
we need more Hillary and we need more
Hillary quick Democrats are already
crushing the GOP in fundraising stupid
libs you're supposed to crush on the GOP
yes the senator from South Dakota can
have as much time as he will Hoss
who see the fact is we need Hillary to
rile up our base so what do we do when
Hillary isn't relevant anymore same
thing I do when my therapist tells me to
stop bringing up my ex-wife talk about
her anyway just look at this flyer from
the Pennsylvania special election that
happened last month stop Hillary stop
Pelosi stop Lam stop her from what you
ask she's not running for anything it
doesn't matter just seeing her name
makes most people's buttholes shiver
West Virginia said a candidate Evan
Jenkins gets it so I won the places that
are optimistic moving forward and his
whole campaign was looking backwards
it's Hillary who's got it backwards the
big city she won are the places flooding
our state with heroin
Chicago's the murder capital of America
yet they want to take our guns away
that's backwards yes Hillary guns
Chicago
that's how you win votes in West
Virginia he knows that talking about
Hillary in a campaign ad is like
bringing a Wolverine to a job interview
very effective that's why the National
Republican Senatorial Committee is using
her and attack ads for candidates in ten
different states you could put half of
Trump supporters into what I call the
basket of deplorable homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic you name it
Islamophobia Islamophobe as llama llama
fur llamas warm up as llama the llama of
Islamophobic you name it oh man
and let's say we can't recycle Hillary
is literally the only renewable resource
we care about
listen Hill we need to talk I know
you're still watching because I told you
not to and you love breaking the law so
look Hillary this is just between us
come back without you we've got nothing
I mean seriously
conservatives are running out of ideas
we're grasping at straws trying to ban
trans people from the military with the
get that and the border wall is still
just a bunch of big tile samples I wish
I knew how to quit attacking you
but I don't you bring out the worst in
me which is my best future for baby
please don't leave the national
conversation look I got some Chardonnay
and some hot sauce which you can put on
your favorite food human babies stay
with me Hilary
[Music]